okay how is donnie boy going to make
America great again we've been talking
about for a while how we're going to
measure or figure out if Donald Trump
has made America great again here are
some metrics which we will be able to
judge president Trump by many of these
according to Trump's own criteria themes
of the day at Trump's inaugura at the
convention rather make America safe
again make America work again make
America first again a flashback to an
anti-semitic slogan as I mentioned and
from his inauguration speech Trump also
said we're going to make America strong
again wealthy again proud again safe
again and of course great again by the
way has any president recycled a
catchphrase so many times in such a
corny in relentless way that's sort of a
sidebar discussion though okay so Pat
let's take a look at our metrics here we
have the data for people watching from
george w bush barack obama and of course
these are the measurements we will be
evaluating some of the measurements we
will be using to evaluate donald trump
unemployment unemployment was up three
point six percent during george w bush's
tenure and down three-point-one percent
under president obama's presidency his
two terms what will the numbers be under
Trump will see civilian labor force
participation this is a big one for
trumpets civilian labor force
participation was down 1.5% under Bush
and three percent under Obama Trump
talks about it as if this is the real
unemployment of course this is not a
perfect measure because when baby
boomers retire in huge numbers as they
are because of their age labor force
participation goes down it's not a
reflection of the economy if the economy
is so good that a couple that previously
had both people working no longer needs
both people to work and one of the one
of the people in the couple chooses not
to work maybe to raise kids at home or
maybe just to help with family or
whatever that lowers the labor force
participation even though it's the
result of something good in the economy
so we can only glean limited information
from this but the Trump is like it so
we'll check it out
median household income down 1,500 bucks
under Bush up 1,500 bucks under Obama
what will it do under Trump poverty up
two point six percent under Bush down
slightly under one percent under Obama
how will trump do gdp growth up two and
a quarter percent per year under Bush up
3.43 point fourteen percent per year
under Obama GDP growth is also deceptive
because if you have for example more
crime and you spend more on prisons that
raises GDP but it's at a reflection of
something good in the economy and not
really trade balance trumpet said he's
going to fix the trade deficit which was
forty billion under Bush 45 billion
under Obama the Consumer Price Index up
43 under Bush up 24 under Obama far
lower inflation under Obama that Bush
will see under Trump the S&P 500 down
forty two percent under Bush up a
hundred and sixty-seven percent under
Obama what will stocks do under Trump
and of course stocks only relevant to
part of the economy not everybody own
stocks and even among people that do
stock ownership heavily concentrated
under the riches the deficit was up one
point fifty five trillion under Bush
down ten billion under Obama what will
happen to the deficit under Trump again
deficit is not debt please don't get
confused and send me rantings of lunacy
misunderstanding what these terms mean
the average gas price up 89 cents per
gallon under Bush down 35 cents per
gallon under Obama not in and of itself
hugely important but reflective of some
economic realities and lastly homicides
per hundred thousand people down 0.1
percent under Bush down 0.5 percent
under Obama and of course as many of us
know crime generally has been decreasing
in the United States for a very long
time these are some metrics Pat and
we've got data will be able to measure
and we'll see what the data is under
president Trump maybe he will make
America great again I don't know what
that would mean because numbers have
improved so significantly under
President Obama but that's his slogan
and we'll see if he sticks to it yeah
and by pretty much every metric there I
mean we're in a better position now than
we were eight years ago of course
pretty amazing that Trump was able to
win on this message that America's not
great that he alone can fix it and I
guess he's supporting his argument by
putting forth alternate effects
alternative factor than you say yeah and
you should see the emails I get from
people who just have no idea they have
no idea what happened under President
Obama send me your thoughts about this
i'm on twitter at d pakman we now have
the metrics by which we will be judging
the greatness of America under President
Donald Trump today's show is brought to
you by godaddy where you can buy your
own domain name build a website or use
any of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save thirty percent at try godaddy.com
slash david go daddy has actually been
the official host of the david pakman
show website for many many many years
the 24 7 customer support has been a
very good thing for us i've called them
at really odd times when we've had
website issues and they are always
available they are the largest domain
registrar and whether you have a new
idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com slash david